I'm a fighter because that's all I've
known how to be my name is Tonya Smith
and I'm a competitive historical fencer
we train in a system developed by 14th
century master and practice until the
16th century we've built a really
awesome community of women and we're all
doing it together
I train and teach in longsword it's my
primary weapon
I'm 5-2 and my long sword comes up to
shoulder level it's empowering and fun
you can use it to cut you could use it
to thrust you can get close and range
and grapple and really just kick-ass
with classes were very very small in the
beginning it felt like I was the only
woman and being the token girl it was
something I was comfortable with at
first but as I got better and as I
started developing my goals as a fighter
I realized I wanted to have a community
of other women with shared philosophies
an event I planned was a women's
tournament one of the first of its kind
in the US
people will view openings event as
lesser but I shouldn't have to beat
someone who still with my height or
double my weight to prove that I am a
good fencer the standard should be
beating the best fighters
women make good fighters because they
want to be there they put their heart
and souls into it
you don't do this because you're forced
to be there you don't do this because
there's an expectation to be there they
do it because they're passionate about
it
you